the underground railroad's engine was
fueled by heartbeats and dreams
chugging towards change we are back with
chelsea clinton
who co-created the she persisted chapter
book series
and in its first installment installment
she persisted
harriet tubman is out now it
is incredible but much more importantly
than my opinion joining us to talk about
it please welcome our resident reviewer
jonah larson who has a very special
guest with him
it's her first time on the show i'm so
excited
his sister
hi mercy hi chelsea hi mercy hi
jonah hi drew hi chelsea i'm 13 now drew
just turned 13 two days ago oh
congratulations
jonah you're an official teenager and
although you were born
50 years old and wiser than most people
i know
i congratulate you on getting into the
teen years
happy birthday thank you very much i'm
so glad to be back on the show again
reviewing a book
with my special sister mercy thank you
jonah and mercy i can't think of anyone
also as i said to
the incredible chelsea clinton how
qualified she is
to hold the conversation in today's
times
and jonah and mercy you are the most
qualified souls
to speak of this book please take the
floor
so to start with we absolutely loved the
book
there were so many amazing messages
throughout it and about
how harriet tubman persisted and i'm not
mercy take over and share her thoughts
about it because she has some really
good ones
yes i do um so
i loved the book because harriet
she risked she cherished her freedom
after she after she
went came to freedom and escaped from
slavery
um i liked how she cherished her freedom
so much that she
risked her life to bring other people to
freedom
and she's just one of the women in
history
who is strong like
your mom here for example she is a very
strong woman
um and
i just i just loved the book
yes it was really nice and just in our
family
there's just there's tons of women we
look up to and tons of people we look up
to
from we need some extra strength and
some support when we're going through a
hard time
and one of those women chelsea
is your mom
and she's right up there with michelle
obama and rosie the editor
and those are some of the women that we
look to when we need strength in the
larsen family
and so thank you and please thank your
mom for me for helping
keep us strong and making us persist
and those are the people who look to
when we need to persist in something
and keep going and i thought it was just
so
serendipitous that your first book
was about harriet tubman and i
actually did harry tubman and i dressed
like her for my school presentation
oh mercy and jonathan
oh matter of fact i even crocheted part
of her outfit and she did such a good
job and it was really nice to be able to
learn more about harriet tubman
oh well you know mercy i hope that um
maybe you can send us a picture so we
can see you uh dressed as harriet tubman
yeah
in the jonah health crochet for you
um and i love that you have my mom and
mrs obama and rosie the riveter
bobbleheads
with you um i think that is a great
trifecta and i will certainly
um pass on what you said to my mom when
i talk to her later
and i'm so um i'm so proud that you like
uh that you like the book that you uh
kind of are drawing
such inspiration from harriet i think
andrea who wrote the book did such a
magical job
of helping show how harriet really
persisted her whole life
when she first you know tried to escape
slavery when she was a kid
um and you know really till the end of
her life when she was
you know fighting for her pension of
having kind of been
in the union army of the civil war
helping to take care
of other um civil war vets and other
formerly enslaved
people you know that she persisted and
stood up and fought for what was right
from when she was you know even younger
than jonah and mercy are
until you know the end of her life i
just
find her example um gives me a lot of
inspiration and the best sense is really
challenging hopefully to all of us
to always do the right thing and chelsea
i love the she persisted books
and i read them to my own girls olive
and frankie and i really loved this
detail in the book where in the back it
says how you can persist and it's
three pages of points
of how you can carry this as a human in
actionability uh in very specific ways
throughout your days and lives and i
found that incredible i also think it's
so interesting
that uh penguin random house is uh
issuing these books
one a month so there will be 12 two in
december
and i think the rollout program of these
books is
very unique and something i wanted to
mention because i was really inspired by
it
as i am inspired by jonah and mercy
chelsea i'm so inspired by you
to be in your guys company today is
makes this just an incredible day and
especially
in light of everything that is happening
to
feel safe and insightful with eloquent
aspirations historical references and
the necessary intentions of how we
proceed
in this life and in this world thank you
so much
all of you for this enlightened and
utterly beautiful conversation
thank you for having me on the show
thank you mercy i'm so happy you're here
finally let's do this
again jonah i love you happy birthday
and chelsea clinton she persisted
harriet tubman is available
right now chelsea thank you for being
here
[Music]
you